this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions this is the ramsey show it's
where we talk about your life
specifically your money your work and
your relationships i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague george campbell
we're here for you this hour to take
your calls it is a free call somebody
out there needs breakthrough today and
we're going to help you do it we're
going to have fun
along the way triple eight eight two
five
five two two five is the number triple
eight eight two five five two two five
uh great looking crowd out in the lobby
of ramsey solutions watching the show
live here good to see you fine folks
today as well george how you doing i'm
doing great ken i got to say i'm looking
at the screen and you look real tan
which tells me you've been in the sun
haven't you yes this is not a spray tan
uh
i wasn't gonna assume well you know
these people the people that watch it
live on youtube have opinions well we uh
just got back from a nice vacation not
together mind you yeah thank you thank
you for speculating fresh back from
vacation
fun in the sun
uh swam with dolphins in cabo james i
can't wait to tell you about that it was
uh a life-changing experience maybe
we'll work it into the show dolphins
swim with ken coleman thank you george
there we go no they i was star struck by
kalea uh sweet nine-year-old dauphin uh
but i digress we are not here to talk
dolphins we're here to talk about
breakthroughs getting you where you want
to be let's get it started in los
angeles california dan you are on
the ramsay show what's up
how are you guys doing we're living the
dream what's going on with you
excellent good
so
my situation is
we have been talking about actually
moving to nashville for the past few
years
the two biggest hold ups are family
obviously
but then my business
so my wife just got a permanent work
from home job
which is huge because we'd have an
income but my business has taken off in
the past few years and i'm i'm willing
to start it over there and i i know i
can um it sounds incredibly daunting but
um we're also you know willing to do
whatever we have a three-year-old
daughter
and we're just
kind of done here for a multitude of
reasons sure um
i'm sure you've heard it a thousand
times um
but we're just not really sure how to do
it because
so do you know do we sell our house
we'll have a decent amount of equity to
buy a new house do we buy a house
immediately
do we rent which i really don't want to
do i feel like it's just throwing away
money but at the same time it does sound
prudent only because
then we can find the exact house we want
sure okay i'll tell you what george and
i are going to walk you through uh what
you need to do but let's get a couple
pieces of information with your wife's
job will you all be able to forget
renting or moving for the moment but
will you be able to live off of her
income
for a month two three months four months
or are you guys going to be really
really tight until you get your business
or some income up and going what's
what's the situation no i've saved i'm a
saver so i've saved a decent little
chunk of change
plus like i said we'll have quite a bit
of equity in our house so
i don't want to use i don't want to use
that to live on at all i want to put
that all towards the house and get my
mortgage as low as possible if i could
get without a mortgage i'd be ecstatic
but i don't think that's going to happen
in this environment so so income isn't
the issue and uh so now this if i were
you
uh and i'll let george address the whole
rent is throwing money away myth uh but
if i were you and we knew nashville
excuse me we knew nashville was the
place all right
um i would be making several trips here
you got cash to do it have you done it
have you found housing where you go we
could with the sell of our house in
california make a really strong down
payment the way we teach at ramsey
solutions 20
can you do a 15-year you know
have you figured that out or are you
going to have to rent for a while just
to be able to get in that position
no so we we visited last september um
and we actually just talked my wife
can't really leave right now because her
job's somewhat new but
i talked about going out again in the
next few months too we scouted a little
bit while we were there we loved
franklin
but that's really the only place we went
so we wanted to branch out a little bit
more
but the the down payment is no problem
i'm definitely looking within our budget
we could put
at least half down i'd like to put even
more down on a house
then what are you afraid of because i'm
hearing all positive things here so what
are you starting my business over is the
is kind of amazing
so i i'm a
full suite real estate marketing i do
photography videography
floor plans virtual tours all that so
i'm an architectural and real estate
photographer
okay how long did it take you how long
did it take you to get that business up
and running in california when you
started it
quite so
i got up to about 60 grand a few years
ago and now i'm at 200.
um i've made 200 for the past two years
how long did it take how long did it
take you to go from zero to two hundred
thousand
ten years
okay how long did it take you to go from
zero to sixty
about five years okay
and now that you know what you know
how much faster could you do it now that
you've done it before
that's the thing and i i know that be
and i'm i'm not a bragger at all but i'm
i'm good at what i do and i know that i
have that confidence good but you'll get
here you'll make connections you'll
build your client list you'll get
connect with some great real estate
agents nashville is a hot market i have
no concerns that a guy like you is going
to get this business up and running soon
especially with the financial position
that you're in how much capital do you
need to start this business over again
we come to nashville not
not much at all i i have my whole system
in place it would really just be
marketing
in nashville that that's really the only
expense so so here's what i'm hearing
i'm just gonna tell you what i'm hearing
dan i'm hearing that you have a lot of
equity in your home
your wife's got a really good remote
work job you've you've started a real
estate
business kind of an ancillary type
service business and you've built it to
a very nice income once before
you're coming to one of the hottest real
estate markets in the country in
nashville
you've got money saved for the little
bit of capital you need to start it
and you we know you can live off of your
wife's income for several months and you
could get another day job
while you were out hustling and building
relationships george i that's what i
hear dan do you hear that do you hear
anything silly or risky or crazy scary
in that narrative that i just repeated
back to you
no from what you said i don't all i did
was repeat back to you what you told us
yeah you just got ken coleman
boom
so is that a thing and it is now so dan
i would i would come here i would rent
at least six months if not a year to
figure out where you want to live
totally stack up more cash you'll be
able to put down a giant down payment
and pay that mortgage off very quickly
and we live in this county that we're in
williamson county which is where
franklin is you mentioned the 11th
wealthiest county in the nation which
means people want to sell their homes
for top dollar and they want a great guy
to market it for them get the high-end
video all of that so i think you're
going to do great here and dan
stacy and i when we moved here eight
years ago to join ramsey solutions we
rented for two years with three kids we
did not throw any money away and i want
you to change that narrative too i'm
throwing money away to i'm giving myself
options
this is buying yourself some patience
buy yourself some time get settled where
do we want the kids to go to school
what's the best place for us given our
work from home situation what's the
market look like renting is not throwing
money away renting is giving you options
giving you time to make the best
decision dan you're a good dude you've
done it the right way you're an
entrepreneur small business person you
are the american dream way to go pal
thanks for the call don't go anywhere
more of those kind of calls coming up
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm ken
coleman george campbell is with me this
hour we're here for you
you've got a money question a work
question a relationship question a life
question uh a fun suggestion we'll take
it all you gotta get through the
screener though that's all on you but
once you get through we're here for you
triple eight eight two five five two two
five so george a lot of people starting
to freak out
about the rising interest rates
real estate are we in a bubble is has it
popped what's gonna happen oh my gosh
the sky is falling and of course there's
a headline for everyone oh yeah no
matter what your opinion or your fear is
around real estate you can find yourself
a headline nobody wants to click on the
headline that says hey everything's
going to be fine right
well we've got that headline that's
right uh very nice george it was a very
nice you gave me a good segue i'm here
for that because next week you
dave ramsey rachel cruz hosting a live
stream event called real estate reality
check where we're gonna tell you what
george
that everything's okay everything is
gonna be okay and it's free so you don't
even have to pay for the pleasure of
hearing us say everything's going to be
okay and we're going to do it with facts
with uh analysis with humor with stories
it's going to be a good time so bottom
line you're going to find out why the
real estate market is not going to crash
why it's still a good time to buy or
sell so don't miss this event it's a
live stream event called
real estate reality check
next thursday july 14th a week away yeah
register for free right now and get the
answers you need to make a confident
decision ramsay solutions dot com slash
reality check that is the site to sign
up ramsey solutions.com
slash reality check are you going to uh
get the guitar out and sing everything
we have not going to be all right but it
might be a realization that's in your
range well kumbaya and give us a little
a little bar everything is going to be
all right a little red james is looking
at me like if you dare sing a lick this
thing jordan sings very well give me a
little everything i'm going to set up
you have to sign up for the event to
find out george i'm really disappointed
that you didn't take that moment to show
people that you're a very gifted singer
he is they can listen to my music on
spotify ken they don't need to hear it
i wasn't setting you up to pitch your
music i just wanted to have a fun moment
but you did it anyways and we thank you
see now that's what's gonna get get you
in trouble all right matthew is on the
line in san diego california he's a new
listener i'm told
matthew you're on the ramsay show
hey guys thanks for taking my phone call
yeah you bet how can we help sir
um yeah so i'm i'm new uh basically i
went on the internet and googled uh
financial um coaches and the ramsey show
popped up
nice i don't yeah yeah we like the
google we like showing up on the google
don't we george it's it's hard to do and
we did it and i'm glad we well now you
are here matthew why were you looking
for that
well so um i was listening to a podcast
and you guys did a couple segments and i
really really loved it um and i kept
listening to it and then one little five
segment popped up about uh crypto fraud
and um unfortunately in the past couple
weeks i am a victim of crypto fraud oh
man
yeah i got scammed um
all in all about thirty five thousand
dollars oh my goodness is that money you
had
no it's it's a loans that i took out oh
boy
gosh yeah and uh i i thought it was
legit because i originally invested 500
and that grew and i was able to extract
that into my bank account
and so that's when i thought it was real
so they had big promises about returns
on your investment and they proved it
with a little investment to then get you
baited into more is that what happened
exactly
exactly exactly what happened oh boy
so now you're in a 35 000 hole on this
do you have any other debt
yeah so we took out
a personal loan at the beginning of the
year of 25 000
to consolidate uh my wife and i uh
loans we were recently married we got
married last year
we weren't supposed to get married in
2020 but coveted and we had to push it
back
a couple years
because we wanted more than five people
to be there
so we pushed it back and then
we got married uh consolidated all of
our loans and now we are expecting a kid
uh next month our first baby next month
oh congratulations
thank you so yeah so we got a 25 000
personal loan that we took out and then
we have both of our
student loans
and then we have her her car
loan all right so
i'm assuming that you called for us to
help you start come up with a plan to
dig out of this correct exactly yeah so
i was looking through your website um
and there's just there's a lot of
information on there a lot of books and
i was just wondering what would be the
first step for somebody like me to to
start in in this program i love it well
the first step is to not go into any
more debt we've got to stop the bleeding
and make sure we've got our four walls
covered so that's your food utilities
housing transportation do you have all
those bills covered you can make ends
meet
yes okay the next thing we want to do is
get on a tight budget we've got a free
app called every dollar that you can
download and list out your income minus
your expenses we want that to equal zero
meaning you've assigned every single
dollar a job what is your income
household um
my my income i'm salary at at um a
hundred thousand dollars and then my
wife is hourly she brings home maybe
about uh
50 000 so we're about 150. okay great
and what's the total amount of consumer
debt you guys have
uh probably a little over
a hundred thousand okay
so what we're going to do is lay them
out smallest to largest and i don't want
you doing any more consolidation loans
because that's not fixing any any
problems here we're just moving around
the debt and feeling like we did
something
okay and so i want you to separate all
the debts put them in a spreadsheet
whatever you need to do list them out on
paper smallest to largest and ignore the
interest rate don't even write the
interest rate down and i want you to
make minimum payments on all of those
debts except for the smallest one what
is your smallest debt
uh smallest debt would probably be the
five thousand dollar loan
is that the car
no that that is one of the loans that i
took out to give
to invest to give to the scammers
because they wanted five thousand
dollars to open up um a channel directly
to me oh boy okay well and who's that
loan through
it's through um
um
it's through through my uh bank i don't
know if i i can say it
i'm trying to figure this out the bank
gave you a loan what are the days what
did you say the loan was for
it was for a personal loan oh okay and
then they go whatever you do with that
money is your business
exactly all right so we're gonna knock
out that five thousand dollar debt as
fast as we can how quickly could you do
that do you guys have any money in
savings
yes yes we do we we have um we have a
stock account that has pretty pretty
good amount of money in there
okay let's go ahead and cash that out
now you go look at the tax implications
talk with your tax advisor but we're
gonna just get out of any non-retirement
accounts to scratch up as much cash as
we can to attack this debt how much do
you have in stock
uh right now we got a little over 10
000.
okay all right so yeah i would cash that
out the tax burden won't be big on that
and you'll knock out that first debt
today
okay and once you feel that progress
we're gonna keep going down the list
until we knock out all of the debts
using that debt snowball method that i
just walked you through
and if that means cashing out till you
just have a thousand dollars in savings
for a while i'm okay with that because
right now this is
your hair should be on fire at this debt
and so that might mean you're getting a
side job to bring your income up to 150
so that you're not trying to plow
through this for the next few years
yeah i i um i i work in agriculture so i
got plenty of plenty of work um i picked
up a a second job
um so i'm scraping you know it's minimum
wage but you know i'm just great doing
as much as i can to to bring we want to
give to you something you're asking
about resources i'm going to gift you
financial peace university and i want
you to sit down with your wife watch all
nine video lessons and with that it'll
come with every dollar our premium
version to connect with your bank and
start your budget and that's all
included in ramsey plus so hang on the
line austin will uh make sure we get
that taken care of and over to you but
man you got to get real serious about
this we got to stop playing around with
crypto and stocks and i mean you touch
the hot stove now and so you know
um that that was a bad move so i feel
good about that part ken that the
behavior changes he's ready for it yeah
and and matthew welcome because you're
joining throngs of people that have made
bad financial decisions and i i think
the word i want to share with you as we
let you go is i don't want you to have
any shame
um
the the bad news is you made some some
bad financial decisions the good news is
there is a plan there's a way we're
giving it to you financial peace and
you're gonna climb out of this and
you're gonna be better for it so get
your head up you'll get out of this
but you're gonna have to really really
hustle for a season but on the other
side of this is gonna be true freedom
and we are here to walk with you along
the way thank you for listening watching
and for calling in don't move more
ramsay show coming up right around the
corner
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
welcome back america this is the ramsey
show where we talk about your life we're
talking about your money we talk about
your work you talk about your
relationships they're all tied together
you know if you've got a dumpster fire
going on
in in your in your money it's gonna
affect your relationship it's gonna
affect how you perform at work if you're
in a dumpster fire of an office with
toxic co-workers and a pinhead leader
who has no idea uh how to treat people
that's gonna affect you at home
and
you know this is why we do what we do is
for breakthrough so that you can be who
you were uniquely created to be and live
that life and and live it with abundance
and and total financial peace so excited
that you're with us uh george campbell
with me uh we we we think we're kind of
fun like we think you know what we're
going to get you your
clients but we also think we're going to
have fun doing it so uh we're going to
have a fun show today
doesn't have to be awful at on some
level people listen for entertainment
as well as some education yeah so we're
going to treat you well we're going to
respect you and uh we're going to help
you out and we're very very excited that
you're here in fact george uh the people
have spoken
um i'm also self-proclaimed man of the
people over on the ken coleman show i
like to say that all the time but in
this case you've had a lot of viewers
and listeners send you uh a particular
tick tock video that they're up in arms
about yeah so i get these videos all the
time since we've been reacting to
different videos on social media on tick
tock and instagram and i'll get dms or
tagged at least 10 times a day wow on
random videos where they go you gotta
debunk this you gotta reach oh i like
this and so there's this one particular
video that has just been nagging me i
get it at least once a week for the last
three months so i thought we'd play it
for our viewers and listeners and what
you're going to see in this video is a
woman talking about 401ks and how
terrible they are is this a financial
expert of some sort we have no idea oh
we don't even know no one knows it's the
internet ken it's just an interview and
so okay below that is a guy reacting to
her video oh and he's pointing in
agreement and i know who this guy is so
we'll talk about it after all right
let's let's let's get it guys let's
watch
this 401k was never meant as a big
retirement plan a 401k was developed
because after the depression people were
not getting back into the stock market
so they created a 401k to make it easy
for the average person to get into the
stock market so you really got to
do some rese i mean everybody all of us
need to really do our research when
we're looking at just blindly accepting
advice from somebody so i don't think
today you can save yourself to
retirement i mean the interest rates two
percent right it was it was almost
negative because it was zero something
and the fees you're paying is brings you
negative
um so if you're saving money
are you trying to build as big a nest
egg as possible to live off of and who
knows what's going to happen with
inflation deflation there's so many
factors so i don't think saving and a
401k is a good financial retirement plan
at all
okay now can i
so dramatic yes right and he was very
excited with the finger pointing and the
touching of the ear yeah but i want to
go back to the lady the so-called expert
who says
uh you got to do your research and did i
hear her i want to make sure i heard
this because i was i was doing my own
research on the google while she was
talking about research it doesn't take
much googling to figure out didn't she
say that it was two percent on the 401k
she said a lot of things though okay so
for the lady who said you need to do
your research
while she was blathering on
i pulled it up
and uh the average rate of return on
401ks just over uh five years from 250
2015 2020 was nine and a half percent
there we go so i found that on the
google on my favorite part
immediately she's talking about how
after the great depression 401ks no
401ks didn't come about until 1978. it
got popular in the early 1980s yeah
again i don't know what research is
talking about research lady needs to
take her own financial history class
goodness gracious see this is why and
again i'm not trying to bang on this
this this this this expert but
this is why we got to be careful what we
consume sure somebody put her out there
and she's
she's she's saying nonsense well can i
tell you i know this guy flips it and
then he goes
what was this move that's the new move
by the way james when somebody says
something i like uh next time i'm on
with dave cosy with dave he's going to
say something great he has no context of
this clip and i'm going to go
there we go just point up in the air
like dave's right listen or maybe i
should point this way
anyway i digress i know too much ken and
what do you know about this guy the
reason this video has taken off and it's
been reacted to so many times with
people in agreement yeah guess what
industry all of those people are in
oh
life insurance oh
so the
here's the connecting point all of these
people uh either sell permanent life
insurance indexed universal life
insurance you name it all insurances
that we know are garbage okay stop right
there we have a lot of new people like
record numbers of new people watching
listening all the time why do we think
that those products are garbage george
because they are astronomically more
expensive than term life
and it's trying to do two things at once
it's trying to be insurance and an
investment which is how these policies
are touted they're touted by all these
guys as this is a way better investment
than your 401k your 401ks trash you
should invest with me in this whole life
policy
uh in order to make money and so that
guy in the bottom of the video is an
index universal life insurance salesman
of course he is and on his website on
his his academy he sells it says index
universal life insurance is without
debate the best choice for secure
compounding
so that's the promise they're making and
which why they're all railing off
against the 401k and here's what we
found in our millionaire study ken 10
000 of them 79
of them reach millionaire status through
their employer-sponsored retirement
plans right so this lady's saying 401 k
is terrible what about inflation and
she's just trying to fear monger people
away from doing a wise investment into
hey put your money with me and index
universal life insurance and you'll be
way better off it is such a nonsensical
statement to say that 401ks were not
meant to help people with retirement
it's just it's literally like saying
uh
i don't even know i can't even think of
something so stupid because it's like
it's the whole purpose it is an
investment fund and it allows you to
invest and as you said the real numbers
from the largest millionaire study
that's ever been done ramsay solutions
says that it works and it works over and
over again and again yeah let me give
this further uh some real skin on this
thing
uh the third largest group of
millionaires net worth millionaires from
this study were teachers
now you look at that's all you have to
say but you look at the median income of
teachers in the united states right now
you're looking about 65 68 000 i believe
it is
um it might be 60. it's one of those
three for all your fact checkers out
there so i've got your someone will do
this but the point is is in that range
of income
you are making enough money to invest in
a retirement account like a 401k and
absolutely retire with tremendous
dignity and live a very full life and
we've seen it over and over time and
time again baby steps millionaires are
being created because they follow our
plan baby step forward invest 15 percent
of your household income into retirement
accounts like 401ks and iras roth is
even better so i think what's happening
here ken is a lot of the younger
generations they're poo pooing all of
these old boring antiquated investment
vehicles like 401ks and iras and they're
trying to take shortcuts and get tricky
and go hey if i do this and get this
index universal life policy and some
crypto man i'll be way better off yeah
but as we're seeing where are all the
index universal life millionaires right
i haven't met them yeah go poopoo that
you said you said
i knew you'd like that well i like the
emphasis on that it gave it a little
extra panic thank you papooing you know
so all that being said uh take
everything on social media with a grain
of salt and i'm starting to you know
just you know what wait in the waters of
tick tock and let me tell you it is a
toxic place yeah it is we are swimming
upstream overnight this is a perfect
example people watch this they go this
lady looks like i get a million videos
on a video yeah it was a very uh
erstwhile host was asking the question
so here's the question very seriously
always ask yourself what is it
i think this kind of stuff is like it's
like a purple snow cone
you know it's all all sugary like here's
your little snow cone your great purple
snow cone and you know you bite into it
and it gives you all the feels
there's no nutrition no value at all no
i mean have you ever bitten to a purple
snow cone jordan i've done it before
when you bite into it there's nothing
there it's not like meat or something to
resist it's just like biting into ice
that's what taking on tick-tock advice
can be you think you bit into something
that's good for you oh no oh there's a
crash after the purple snow cones ask
yourself what does this person have to
gain by posting this video and if you
dig into that question you'll usually
find your answer there it is folks
purple snow cone or not let's see
you come to the rams you show that kind
of depth folks
only at the ramsey show do you get that
kind of breakdown all right hey good
news more calls more breakthroughs
coming up this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman george campbell joins me here in
studio as we take your questions triple
eight eight two five five two two five
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverage you get free samples
free shipping and with new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsay and you'll get
the best deal today's question comes
from katie in michigan she says i'm
engaged and my fiancee currently has
fifteen thousand dollars in debt that
he's paying off i am debt free and
currently have 18 000 in savings once
we're married later this year i would
like to pay his remaining debt but i
would like for us to still live below
our means until we pay back my savings
he doesn't agree with this plan
help oh boy george exclamatory help at
the end there yeah for sure well
ken i i am inclined to agree with katie
that it's important we refill
this emergency fund but i don't think he
sees it as that no and the problem is is
uh they're engaged and they are in the
final countdown right oh boy you you
don't want to
kick the can down the road and deal with
this after marriage
we got to find out i feel like this is
like okay time out this is a emergency
press conference right yes we got to sit
down and hash through this
so here's what i'm thinking right now he
sees it as her plan
and his plan i think we need to get on
our plan and that means he needs to
understand where she's coming from i
don't know that she's explained hey this
money is my emergency fund of three to
six months and if something were to
happen i want us to be protected from
whatever happens in the economy a job
loss uh hvac needs to be replaced
whatever it is we need to have the money
in savings so that we don't go into debt
yeah and so i think we need to have a
mindset shift and that's one of the
beautiful things about financial peace
university when you go through it as a
couple you now have a shared language
that you can use to communicate you
understand where each person's coming
from and so i think that would be a
great next step for them because
currently they're on different
wavelengths when it comes to money and i
feel like i'd like to have one-on-one
with this young man
he's yet to discover the universal truth
happy wife happy life
and uh you know he needs to figure this
out you know
not only because of that but because it
actually is the right decision but you
know come on man
figure this out this you got a you got a
really level-headed fiance who's yeah
she's getting in the bank no debt she's
clearly doing something well she's
paying off this knucklehead's debt which
i appreciate when they get married i
appreciate that it becomes our money and
our financial mistakes yeah this katie i
got to tell you this is a full stop
we have got to dig into this you need to
know my heart on this
why i believe this
why i want you to do this
how it's important to the to the vision
that i have for our marriage that's the
key word
what is the vision for our family when
it comes to money yeah
and i think once they nail that down
everything's going to be great but right
now this feels like a solvable problem
yeah oh it absolutely is but it is a red
flag thank you for uh the question katie
all right let's get to the phones
kevin is on the line in maui oh my
goodness george you ever been to maui
never really to go you need to go maybe
we could go see kevin uh depending on
how good the advice is on this call
we'll see kevin you're on the ramsay
show
well both of you would be most welcome
ken and george a real pleasure to speak
to you oh that's awesome kevin we are on
our way to the show accent i was hoping
for ken
kevin how can we help today
well let me let you know i have not had
a credit card in over 10 years i only
use cash and debit cards i am debt free
i own my own home i own our cars
outright i am even a coordinator for
financial community
kevin that's awesome man thank you for
doing that but i i am in a quandary
about how to consistently rent a car
with a debit card and i'll explain why
in february i reserved a car with a
major rental company in memphis at the
international airport they took my money
but after two hours they did not rent me
the car because i have insufficient
credit
so i decided at that moment i'm only
going to use the company that dave
recommends and in may i reserved a car
in st louis had no problem
but yesterday my wife and i flew to oahu
with two of our friends for a day trip i
had reserved a car with the same rental
company at the honolulu airport several
weeks ago
they had already taken my money but for
some reason ran a credit check and again
because my credit was insufficient they
would not rent me the car
and so hallelujah one of our friends had
a credit card and was able to pay for
the car
because if that hadn't happened we would
have literally been stranded without a
vehicle so what's the solution is there
a consistent answer that keeps me from
being stranded somewhere in the south
pacific
oh well now kevin you love a good drama
don't you you like drama
you like some drama kevin because
there's no way you're getting stranded
you could have got an uber you could
have got a driver i was in mexico for uh
the last week and we we didn't have a
rental car we got everywhere we needed
to go so i appreciate the question
george can jump in on this uh he's the
financial guru but come on kevin you're
not getting stranded there because you
can't rent a car
so the key here kevin is to do the
research beforehand and verify with the
company you're renting with that what
their debit card policy is so i just
googled renting a car with a debit card
and immediately budget avis and alamo
immediately came up with a blog about
how they allow you to rent a car with a
debit card i've had a great experience
with enterprise recently where they
sometimes just had a hold 20 hold or
something like that to the card in order
to rent now if you're getting a certain
type of vehicle i have heard that it can
be more difficult to get you know the
giant suv for example are you trying to
rent a specific type of vehicle usually
no no usually the least expensive and
and and in the past they have put an
authorization of like a 500
uh deposit down which i'm happy to do
that's not the problem it's just that
all of a sudden the very same company
that rented me a car two months ago
will not rent me the car here yeah i
wish i could speak to the
inconsistencies
of each company um but there are other
options too outside i mean i haven't had
a lot of poor experiences with this
personally with different companies i
usually rent through you know a site
like costco travel and i've had good
experiences usually a company like
enterprise is great uh but there are
other options we've talked on the show
before about doing uber or lyft if
you're going around a city with good
transportation you can also rent a car
through turo and you can do that with a
debit card have you heard about turo
t-u-r-o no i gotta tell you no big fan
ken's a big fan i've used it several
times this is where basically ken
coleman can list his car for you to rent
yeah it's person-to-person and it's just
an app you download and it'll show you
cars in your area and i've heard from
many of our listeners that they've had
great experiences with turo so that
might be a great option for you to check
out i love turo
kevin's not he's not happy kevin you're
in maui man did you get are you at the
airport stranded right now because i'll
make a couple calls or did you get where
you needed to go
no well we we eventually did because
somebody else was able to rent the car
oh that's right hallelujah unable to
rent the car right and so and that and
that was the thing the very same company
with the very same thing at an airport
rental rented me one two months ago and
didn't rent anyone this time and i just
couldn't understand why wow
i'm a minister and i'm a big fan of
following the rules and having some
level of consistency otherwise
everything's chaos right and so i'm just
trying to find the company
that will you know not put us put us in
a quandary right there at the rental car
company yeah and suddenly you know
because you're right absolutely there's
uber and things like that but the reason
you rent a car is so that you can go out
and explore
and if you explore uber once again i'm
not going to be a very good steward of
my money if i'm spent spending three and
four times what i would normally spend
on that car rental for the day if i go a
different route well we totally feel you
and understand this
big corporations aren't consistent
sometimes and so it's frustrating we
totally feel what you're feeling but
again george gave you some some some
real big-time rental companies maybe the
one in maui they got a district manager
out there who's like you know the
the uh what's the guy's name from the
office the horrible michael scott he's
like the michael scott of the local
rental car company he's got his own
policies who knows so what do you do you
pivot and you touro is an option you
know you go okay i want to explore so
i'm going to get a ride to the house and
we're going to call a local company and
do your debt you a jeep to drive around
maui for the day a schnauzeberry jeep
maybe
ken and i took a call about that one
time we did so yeah the key here is do
your due diligence call that location
get the name of the person the manager
who said yep you can run the debit card
and you'll be okay but it does take a
little bit more work but i'm okay with
that if it means avoiding the credit
card game yeah happy to do that
absolutely all right good stuff good
hour george thank you always fun and uh
to the team uh back there in the control
room there's so many i don't have time
to list them all you folks are amazing
people thousands back there to the
amazing people in the lobby thank you
for watching fun times hey
that's going to do it this is the ranch
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show it's
where we talk about your life
specifically your money your work and
your relationships triple eight eight
two five five two two five is the phone
number triple eight eight two five five
two two five i'm ken coleman joined by
george campbell in the studio this hour
we're here for you great group of people
uh in the lobby uh of ramsey solutions
watching us george like from all over
the country like we're zoo animals and
that's always fun we go out during the
breaks and say hi
and uh as the hour was beginning but
please don't pet us no yeah no peter
makes it awkward no petting we do a nice
firm handshake that's right but you can
bring food
that's true
but you know crap it's like someone
bringing food on a plane be wary of what
you're eating oh yeah see now you'll be
wary if somebody in the lobby comes up
with a smile and a snack i'm going to
try it
you'll do it you'll take fear
i'm not a fearful person i don't think
these people are strangers look at them
they look lovely
well most of the time they're eating
food from our cafe which is free all the
baked goods right right that's one
reason enough to make it met a couple
from uh cincinnati
last hour i naturally asked him did you
bring some skyline chili because if you
won't eat it james the producer but if
you he never turns down food 14 hour old
room temp chili tell me
i absolutely would try it and james
knows i'm telling the truth i absolutely
when i used to host the youtube show
years ago people would bring food in the
lobby and i would eat it that's why they
call them iron stomach coleman
that's his old nickname in high school
no ironside
nobody's ever called me that but that's
fantastic all right shannon is waiting
patiently in seattle washington shannon
you're on the ramsay show
hello hi thank you for taking my call
you bet
my question is i want to be able to um
i'm 51
and
i
want to be able to own my home free and
clear by about 65
i want to be able to increase my roth
ira contribution and sep contribution
and also to be able to help my kids with
some college expenses
to do so my question is do i sell my
current home
use the profit uh move to a less
expensive town less expensive home
um try to do some extra mortgage
payments or do i stay here until my kids
are done with
school which would be approximately
eight years
uh they're ages 10 to 14
so they're young still
i mean relatively young
how much would you want to make on your
house
i would make
after everything i'd say about 250.
okay okay
yeah
what about your job is that
local yeah i'm self-employed actually um
so could you move further out and be
okay
i could
yeah it's
one of the reasons why i'm hesitant or
something to consider is this property
the house that i have now i have a
separate um
adu
that i rent out for about 900
a month
okay so you choose that i'll set my
mortgage
yeah i lose that you lose 10 grand a
year i i think george the question i've
got uh shannon for you is
how much does selling the house fast
forward how much does it really add to
uh the goals that you've got because
there's going to be some downside uh
obviously losing the rental income
there's the move you're not going to be
able to pocket all of that 250 000
you're going to put some of that into
the next house so i just wonder if
you're working no i don't want to put
the whole amount in i have i have six
months emergency fund i have
i have
i don't have any other debt other than
the house
so what's stopping you from just staying
in the house continuing to invest 15
save for college
and uh once the kids are gone hopefully
we have the house close to paid off
what's left on the mortgage
well that's what's kind of the tricky
part uh i owe 546
on the mortgage
um so it's a pretty significant amount
and what's the payment on that
the payment on it is only 2500 but the
reason is
about 12 years ago
um
well i adopted a couple of my children
and a lot of happened and so
and that's when the market crashed and
i renegotiated my mortgage with the
lender
to a 40-year loan
and i owe
366 000 at four percent
and then they created a separate account
180k at zero percent
so the challenge is if i make extra
payments of any kind it goes only to the
zero percent part it doesn't go to
paying off
the part that's accruing interest yeah i
don't like this this whole plan sounds
wonky um well from this standpoint i
kind of like selling and getting out
from underneath of it yeah i mean it
sounds like you you might be able to
refinance but i want you on a 15 year
sounds like you're on a 30 year right
now correct or a 40
well a 40-year right i'm going to still
have 30 years on but if you refinance to
a 15 you couldn't afford it
no and so that tells me you have too
much house and too much mortgage and for
that reason i would sell yes
and downsize to something the more
realistic uh in your area
yeah have you looked into that what that
would look like do you still need all
the space
well i do i have three children in fact
actually the house that we're in
is a little bit too small for us um i
have
i converted part of my garage
for my son to use as a bedroom it sounds
like we need to relocate somewhere where
cost of living is lower
is that an option
it is i i live in a really um
very sought after area i bet kind of an
exclusive nice
it
doesn't matter shannon you know i know
it's sought after and i know it's gonna
stink you know pulling up steak schools
are really good yeah but there's good
schools in other places
there's good schools in other places
this is a reset for you financially that
is gonna just i think you have to weigh
it i think this is a good exercise for
you to go okay oh i mean really my kids
are in really good schools we live in
this really nice area that's all nice
nice nice and so that's going to be a
negative if we move but then let's write
down the positives for if we sell and
what that does for your financial future
and the goals that you have for your
kids and for you just mentally and
emotionally i mean this is this is a
huge weight of debt on your shoulders
and you told me you want to be debt free
by 65 which is 14 years from now
and that plan could happen if you're on
a 15-year fixed and you paid it off
early that's very realistic but at this
juncture looking 14 years out and you're
spinning your wheels trying to pay off
over a half million dollars in debt
while trying to increase your
investments while trying to save for the
kids college it's just too much and so
for that reason i'm going to downsize we
can find a school in a different area
and maybe not downsizing house but
downsizing mortgage
yeah and again this is i understand what
i'm about to say doesn't really you know
it doesn't go down easily for a lot of
people that are in the situation but
your kids are adaptable
if you've got to stick two of them in a
room together they'll be fine
you know because it's for a short season
if you are resetting financially so this
oh everybody needs their own room and
everybody and she didn't say that but
it's like well but i mean kids are
adaptable yeah and i i think these kids
in today's world need to be a little bit
more uncomfortable shall we say i like
that cranky old man but it's got such a
curve imagination i am a curmudgeon
great word by the way thank you
uh during the break we'll see if you can
spell it first time without any kind of
aids at all all right uh the curmudgeon
and the camel will be back right after
this break
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague george
campbell and we are here for you
triple eight eight two five five two two
five uh we got our money calls uh but
today i'm in studio so if you're
struggling at work or you're going can i
wanna level up
is now the time to get a raise what's
the best way to do it i'm thinking about
a different career path i'm working for
a toxic
leader who's a complete bonehead
and sucking the life out of me or i work
with gossipy toxic co-workers how do i
avoid all that these are things i talk
about daily on the ken coleman show we
can take those calls as well because
again
your greatest wealth building tool is
your income thank you george can i tell
you i'm gonna touch your horn for a
second we just met a sweet family out
there from north carolina yeah and the
young lady said kim i got a job using
your principles thank you george it's
true and so you know what she did this
was a couple years ago is that right if
i remember correctly and she was in the
interview process
and she asked the manager three
questions
and we won't reveal those but i teach
people that the interview is just as
much for you as it is for them and the
way to stand out in the interview and
this young lady did was ask very
intentional questions and the manager
said to her
wow
nobody's ever asked me those questions
and she stood out because of the
questions that she asked so that was
really cool i got a little goosebumps
when you told me that that was really
fun
and uh the other the sister is in town
for a dance contest uh nationals good to
know yeah she's into hip-hop dancing so
i thought you two should do a little we
should do a collab you guys should do
something on the next commercial break
you only get to see that if you come
live ramsay solutions world at least
once a show ken says it calls me the
dancing camel and that you need to tune
in for that
hasn't happened yet has not happened all
right michael's up in tulsa oklahoma
michael how can we help
hey thanks for taking my call guys you
bet what's up
um
i got to listen to dave a couple about a
month ago and me and my wife i've been
talking to her about it i'm going to try
to get out of bed and i just want to try
to worse uh know where to start awesome
we thought about
canceling my 401k for a while to use
that extra money to start paying off
some debt i didn't know that was smart
that is about the smartest thing you can
do and it's very hard for most people to
do because it feels counterintuitive
because you know you're getting a match
potentially and you feel like well this
investment is going to pan out but it's
kind of like it's tapping your head and
rummage your stomach at the same time it
can be very difficult to do multiple
things at once and wonder why you're not
making progress and what's stopping the
401k does it does two things number one
like you said it actually frees up cash
flow for you to attack the debt but
number two it lights a fire under you to
get rid of the debt faster because you
want to get back to that compound growth
and i actually like the second reason
better
because it changes your behavior
and so pausing what are you what are you
investing right now how much of your
income uh it's about six percent so
uh roughly about 600 a month something
like that five hundred dollars that's a
great chunk
here's the beautiful part you're gonna
pause the six percent it's gonna go down
to zero for a short time but when you
come back you're going to come back
swinging at 15
almost triple what you're investing now
it's beautiful and that's what gets me
excited so michael you're on the right
track i would absolutely pause the 401k
how long is it going to take to pay off
the debt if you do all these things you
pause the 401k get a side job do
whatever it takes sell stuff
uh it's probably going to take a while
because we've got quite a bit on credit
card uh house and a truck what's your
income we just sold one
uh roughly i make i get started new job
about six months ago but
uh
probably going to be pushing 80. okay
no my wife just went to work and started
a job but hers is going to be contingent
on a contract give me a rough number so
we're not 100
uh hopefully
30 36 thousand right so we're talking
115 000 in income how much debt do you
have total consumer debt
uh
probably with the house credit card no
house take out the mortgage
no uh
about 70 60 000 okay i heard there was a
there we go i heard there was a truck in
there george what's the truck knows how
i feel about trucks yeah
oh yeah well we just sold one well when
i started my new job i got to cut the
truck so i don't we sold one uh that's a
neural one for my wife because of low
mileage uh it's
probably
we think about fifty thousand dollars on
it hey what what could you sell it for
today
uh
unfortunately we got a price on it
one
that we're way up
upside down on it but you're telling me
that just like most of your debt is just
in this truck
uh yes yeah can i i listen michael just
humor me for a moment this is all on
your behalf
you said that you bought it for 50 or
you got you got debt on it to the degree
of 50 000. sorry i can't can't think for
a second um and then where did you get
the uh quote from it was it a trade-in
value from a dealer
uh a dealer just by uh just buying it
yeah but they're always going to you
tried to sell it out right yeah yeah
yeah so could you get private sale for
it probably over 50. what is the truck
tell me what the truck is
uh ram 1500 a ram 1500 what year
uh
21. oh my god ken i've always wanted to
ask this is you got a hemi
yeah
yes
sorry michael george has no idea what he
even i've seen the commercial he has no
idea uh okay
have you so here's here's one homework
assignment for you michael before you go
to bed tonight i want you to look
for uh private sellers
uh
also kelly blue book
value on your truck as it stands right
now in tulsa oklahoma i want to see what
you can get for that because george i
want you to walk him through
even if he's if let's say he can get 48
for it or if
walking through why we want to attack
this truck situation oh yeah well number
one the interest michael what's the
interest on this thing what's your
payment
uh i think my wife said the interest is
like three percent or something like
that and we're paying like 800 something
oh my goodness
800 bucks a month that could be going
towards your actual goals instead of
going towards the depreciating asset
yes sir so i'm thinking we need to get
rid of this truck and we also don't
recommend anyone buying new cars unless
they're a millionaire which are you guys
net worth millionaires yet
uh not even closer i want you to get a
lot closer and part of that is going to
be selling this truck even if you're
upside down on it and you need to go to
your local credit union and get a
personal loan that's the only time i
tell you to do that
because of how dire this is and so if
you can scrape up the cash to cover the
difference that's even better do you
guys have any money in savings
uh very little very little okay
well i want you to change your whole
financial picture and part of that is
getting rid of this truck and then
you'll have very little debt left to
tackle then we're gonna get our three to
six months of expenses then we can get
back to investing michael what kind of
work do you do
uh i am a
surgical instrument tech
interesting
uh are you a handy guy
outside of the surgical tech work you're
pretty handy
oh yeah i'm trying to work
a job and everything else but i'm not
gonna lie the last four years i've
traveled so much i kind of want to see
my family a little bit i get it i get no
i need to do it but you know i've missed
so much i kind of i get to make up time
if i can but i'm all for that and i'm
not actually suggesting what i think you
think i'm suggesting i'm saying for a
short term let's say that you're upside
down in this truck we figure out maybe
it's five grand could you do some side
hustle handyman work to come up with
that extra five so you don't have to go
get a loan and now we're and we scrap
together five thousand ten thousand for
a minivan or something that's old
so you're with the family but we get out
of this debt faster i mean this truck is
a huge part of your debt situation and
then with you slowing down stopping the
payments of the 401k
you could really get on top of this
pretty quick right george
i feel the progress already i'm excited
for them yeah so i mean i this is an
urgency for a season i don't think you
have to trade being with your family to
get rid of this truck but i look at this
in this economy a guy like him george uh
who's got some services to offer can
make some side money pretty quick and
one of the best things the only probably
good things about car debt is it's a
little bit of a reversible
problem it is i can't go sell my student
loans that's true sell that car and get
out that's exactly right and so i kind
of like when we dig in and ask what kind
of debt
it's partially for that reason to figure
out what can we get rid of here to clean
this up faster yeah fun little question
michael for you and your wife i think
over dinner tonight is what would it
feel like if we didn't have
the debt we have
what would it feel like if we weren't
what would we do 800 a month how much
sooner could we retire yeah what kind of
truck could we buy with cash later on
yeah it's a little it's a fun little
game
but it is a way to kind of see what the
future could look like and what does
that feel like and uh
it'll change your perspective change
your context great great great call
thank you michael for trusting us and
the best is yet to be i promise
more ramsey show coming up
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help
go to their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back america you are joining the
conversation here on the ramsay show i'm
ken coleman george campbell is joining
me this hour it's a free phone call to
jump in
we'll talk about your money we'll talk
about your work issues those do uh tend
to coincide george from time to time
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight
eight two five
five two two five uh you have if you've
been engaged in the show for any amount
of time you've heard us talk about how
important it is to have a will everybody
needs a will
there's more to estate planning than
just a will estate planning covers all
the documents plans and conversations
you need to have
in case something happens to you you
don't have to be an eccentric
millionaire with an offshore account to
have an estate plan you
need an estate plan start by checking
out our estate planning checklist
this easy to use tool will help you keep
track of everything you need
walking you through documents
to get
a conversation to have and where you can
go to get more information so you can
get this done
give yourself and your loved ones peace
of mind
by taking care of this stuff ahead of
time download your estate planning
checklist for free at
ramseysolutions.com
estate checklist that's
ramseysolutions.com
estate
checklist alex joins us in austin texas
alex how can we
help good afternoon gentlemen how are
you doing we are living the dream what
are you doing
uh same here hope you're both well good
what's up so um
so i've got about um 28 thousand dollars
in student loans and have fourteen
thousand to throw at it
um the loans are broken up into six
individual loans um the smallest four
are 14k and the largest two are 14k um
i've been listening to the show for
quite a while and i've heard previously
that you guys have advised against debt
consolidation and this isn't a
deconsolidation question but in part you
advise that because the momentum you can
build
through the debt snowball
so i was wondering if i should
uh i know the baby steps would be to pay
smallest to largest but i'm wondering if
i knock out the two largest with my 14k
then i can utilize that momentum to pay
off the other 14k
it feels like a wash to me because
you're going to free up the same amount
of payments right
yeah exactly it's more just i guess the
non-mathematical part of the debt payoff
process that i'm wondering about
the non-mathematical part you're saying
you're going to feel more progress by
paying off the highest loans first
well as i start once i pay those off and
i start to work the debt snowball with
my income uh i would make more progress
i get at least it would feel like more
progress but i agree with you
mathematically it doesn't matter
well
i just think paying off the smallest
ones leaving you with just two loans at
that point
yeah exactly
i would be able to pay off the smallest
four yeah i mean i think knocking out
four leaving with two would feel better
emotionally if we're just talking about
emotions
instead of looking at six deaths now i'm
looking at two and i have half left i've
already done this before i know how it's
how this is going to work now how much
money will you have left over after you
throw the 14 000 at it
uh 1 000. i have 15 000.
cool what's your income
uh about 66.
nice so how quickly can we pay off the
the rest of the debt
uh i used your calculator online it said
uh about two years but i feel like it
would be i get bonuses and stuff so i
imagine uh by the middle of next year
yeah absolutely making 66 paying off 14
you can do that
probably six months
and if you had to if you were an
emergency situation and you had to make
an additional two to three grand a month
you got a couple of ideas how you would
do that
um
definitely been thinking about getting a
second job haven't really given it too
much thought into what i could start
thinking about definitely on think about
it yeah and listen not just not just a
side job
i want you to start thinking okay if i
wanted to make if i had to now this is a
little bit of a mental game here but if
i had to make an additional two to three
a month how would i do that i had to
work a full-time job but i had to come
up with two to three grand more per
month
i had to do it how would i go about
doing it i think that's the question you
start answering because i think you're
gonna be surprised at how possible that
is for you to do and all of a sudden
you've cut that two-year
maybe into six months eight months ten
months a year i mean you really could do
it yeah alex are you getting a tax
refund every year
uh no so i uh i did two years ago and
then i adjusted that uh this past year
so okay uh yeah i'm looking i'm looking
for any other area we can 401k are you
investing at all
no so i i pause that right
as well the hold up in my budget is that
i have a daughter and i mean i know a
lot of people pay for daycare but
daycare is it almost more than rent oh
yeah so
and that's something so
i i i'm gonna be able to do it quickly
it's just uh some additional expenses
yeah well you got it man you really do
just follow the plan i don't think
you're special in this case i would just
pay it off smallest to largest be done
with it and move forward yeah thanks for
the call alex you got this dana is up
next in new york city dana how can we
help
hi how are you guys we are having a
blast what's going on
all right so
i have a dilemma that just happened this
morning the guy the manager that i work
with is quitting today
so they already told him that they're
most likely thinking about
giving me the position which would be a
20 000
raise from what i'm getting now will be
fifty thousand dollars and i'm getting
around like thirty four thousand okay
and
my dilemma is that in september i'm
scheduled to move to canada toronto or
school
um
i'm 23 years old i went to school pretty
late i took a while because i did not
know what i wanted to do and i did not
want to spend money if i did not know
100 what i wanted to do good for you so
yeah why are we going to toronto to
study what a presuming you now know what
it is you want to do
yeah it's digital experience design and
the only reason i have to go to toronto
is because they are the first ones in
the world to make that career a major
it's a very new career product designer
so they're the first ones to make it a
major that i can even go to school for
so tell me a little bit i ended up going
there tell me a little bit more about
what they're going to train you to do
when you say product designer what is
that what's that
end result for you you want to be doing
what every day
so
we basically design interfaces for
companies so like
google has a product designer for
their google site their fitbit like the
products for example like if you're a
product planner for a fitbit you're the
one going out and researching the people
who will be using the fitbit how
they
interact with apps and how what button
should go where like you're basically
doing like the psychology of the design
and then designing it oh i'm very
familiar this is a little bit of a
leading question there because um i
don't think that you need a degree to do
that work
and because no you some people do um
certificates
right so here's my question
um
why i mean you know this to be true and
and it's so true that this school in
toronto is the only place to even do a
major for it that's not necessarily a
good thing that feels like oh we're just
going to throw this out there because
there's a lot of these jobs already and
we'll see if we can get some people in
to pay for it but the fact of the matter
is is you can work your way into that
position and certainly online training
and certificates can get you there so
what would that cost you to to move to
toronto to do this because you're not
working presumably
um
[Music]
so it's 15 000 a year yeah i gotta tell
you
dana
i'd take the promotion
and i would then find a much more
affordable
online option
i'm going to give you a copy of my
number one bestselling book called the
proximity principle which says this in
order to do what dana wants to do
she's got to be around people that are
doing it and in places where it is
happening you need to start hanging
around a lot of product designers and
product managers and people like that in
your spare time and online and through
social
and you get the certificate of the
certification rather that you need i'd
take the promotion if it were me
and i'd find the path
to get where i want to go and it does
not involve sitting in a classroom in
toronto
being taught to do something that it's
already happening out there in the real
world you do not need we've got lots of
product designers here and none of them
have a digital experience degree from
this university in toronto illustrious
toronto university hang on the line the
proximity principle is all you need
we'll give it to you all right don't
move more of the ramsey show coming up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by george campbell we're
taking your questions about your money
your work those two categories are
clearly connected and we'd love to help
you if you are feeling stuck are you
feeling like hey which direction i need
to go uh we'll take those calls today as
well triple eight eight two five five
two two five is the phone number triple
eight eight two five five
two two five let's go to lydia who joins
us on the line in cincinnati ohio lydia
how can we help
hi um thank you so much for taking my
call today you bet you're doing what you
guys do
so my husband and i have started uh to
seriously work the baby steps here just
as a couple as of a couple months ago um
and we've come across two major
questions or concerns while trying to
pay down a significant amount of student
debt um so those questions are for our
current situation is a thousand dollars
enough for the initial emergency fund
and then also can our retirement fund
withstand no contributions for the time
we're doing this um and kind of what
ramifications will we have
uh by not doing so it makes me nervous
there's a lot of pressure for my family
to not cut it back
and it's just made me and my husband
kind of nervous to stop contributing to
that
how much debt do you guys have
um
so it's down to 241 000 of student debt
only
okay
that's all student debt what do you guys
do
yeah so i'm a medical science liaison
and my husband is a chemist
cool and what's your household income
uh yeah so with bonuses somewhere
between 240 and 270 a year
awesome okay so back to your
initial question is one thousand dollars
enough for you guys the answer is
yes and no because the truth is one
thousand dollars was never meant to be
a full emergency fund
but yes it's enough for baby step one
and many many people have done it i know
it's scary but that's kind of part of
the point isn't it because you know
what's scarier to me it's terrifying
pile of 241 000 of debt that you owe
that's a whole lot scarier than having a
thousand dollar starter emergency fund
how much do you have in savings now
um so
i haven't refinanced my student loans
because they're still sitting interest
free um by the grace of god at the
moment we have about 28 000 that we're
gonna dump into this before interest
restarts okay and then what that leaves
you with a thousand to your name
that leaves us with about three
so okay i can cut it back more i guess
it just makes us it has made us thrown
over we have two small kids and we feel
like we keep falling into the caveats as
we've listened to the podcast of oh you
might want a little more than that
what's the caveat
well like the having the young kids
we've had some health issues with the
kiddos where uh it seems like we've kind
of had medical bills back to back which
we pay cash for as we go um
but that's the key but you could cash
flow things as they come up right if
something happened you could pause the
debt snowball and with your income you'd
have an extra five ten thousand dollars
sitting there to cover those emergencies
so really the you know the thousand
dollar emergency fund
um it's really more of like the nuisance
fund
you know it's like something stupid
happens to the card it's an 800 expense
we don't want a jack with a budget boom
we're gonna go there and then you refill
it then you refill it
it's not a as george said a true three
to six month emergency fund it's a
nuisance fund it's an emergency but it's
more nuisance level anything more
serious than nuisance you guys are going
to do what george said you've already
done and what you have done and you're
going to cash flow it i mean there's
there's a reason why you've been able to
save 28 thousand dollars because you
guys have figured out margin in your
monthly budget true
so i want you to change the narrative on
this
you have the income and the ability to
deal with a true emergency situation for
the kids listen i live this stuff out
and uh four years ago my youngest uh
went through some incredibly difficult
stuff with her ear
had to have multiple nights of stay in
the hospital and then reconstructive ear
surgery
well let me just tell you something
like
that we paid for that but we didn't we
paid it right but we paid it we cash
flowed yeah you know we called the
hospitals it here's here's the deal we
aren't going to go into a finance we're
going to pay this and here's what we're
going to pay monthly and we cash flowed
our way through that we didn't we didn't
necessarily you know have to say oh we
have no money left and so
kids medical expenses you're not stuck
with you got to pay all of that up front
and if you cash flow it um it's just
like any other expense well the truth is
3 000 isn't enough either i mean that's
not going to cover a new hvac and so at
either way you're gonna have to cash
flow any big emergencies that come your
way so i would bring it back down to a
thousand to your second question
regarding investing the ramifications
how long would we have to pause
investing in order to do this we're
talking
uh you're making
your income's only going to go up right
you're making at least 250 270 a year
yeah yeah 240 to 270 pre-tax so the
question is how little can we live on so
that we can create so much margin and
throw you know 100 120 maybe more at
this debt and it's gone in two years
so i'm glad you're saying that because
that was kind of one of my questions
also is we're looking at like two and a
half ish years
based on what our current expenses left
over are how old are you here that you
think
uh i am
29 and my husband's 31. okay you're 29
31 which means let's just say two years
you guys go hard at this thing you're
now 31 he's 33 you both have a good
25 30 years plus in your careers left
to now invest way more than you were
because let me remind you you just freed
up 241 thousand dollars worth of
payments that you now have back into
your bank account
which means now we're not just able to
invest some we're maxing things out
we're doing backdoor roth iras we're
getting real wild over here building
wealth and so that's what i wanted
actually good well i would pause all of
that because that will give you the
progress and momentum you need because
hey those student loan payments are
coming back in full swing
this summer it's like the worst movie
trailer ever this summer that's right
student loans isn't that true it's like
that monster truck thing lydia don't
don't worry about your family of course
they want to pressure you they love you
guys they want to see you build wealth
but right now they don't know what it
feels like to have 241 000 of debt
looming in their life so you guys
control your finances follow this plan
i'm telling you it works people have
paid off this debt and more that have
come our way and done this plan you know
george we this is a really good call um
lydia we really appreciate you calling
great questions because there's there's
real psychology involved in this you
know she she think well 3 000 is better
than 1 000. and and i think it's
important that we help people understand
you're going to have to cash flow the
big things
you're just gonna have to deal with it
the reason we say a thousand dollars in
baby step one is because we want to free
up as much cash as possible to get that
snowball truly rolling downhill but it
does freak people out and i get that but
i have taken uh i can count on zero
fingers how many times someone has
called in and said listen we had a giant
emergency thousand dollars didn't cut it
and now our life is over you figure it
out you get creative that's right you go
what can we sell what side jobs could do
what can we get on a payment plan with
the hospital that's right what are the
types of things we can do
so that we don't have to either go into
debt or save up 20 grand before we even
start the debt snowball which again
psychologically you'll never get there
yeah it's true and but and yet you know
either things we worry about the most
rarely happen
that's true you know and so it is
there's a difference between vigilance
and worrying
you know be vigilant you know what do we
need to pay attention to here um but
then you know what we've got a plan we
have common sense
you know we'll figure out a way if
something if a lightning strike happens
if something serious happens well we got
bigger issues anyway exactly and the
money part is just something we'll have
to deal with and i found a lot of those
well what if what if what if it comes
down to a lot of justification on our
part going i don't want to change i like
to sit here in this dirty diaper that
i've created for myself because it's
comfortable and it's mine instead of
going you know what i'm going to light a
fire under our this under my belly i'm
going to go after it i'm going to change
my family tree you know i was worried
you were going to mix metaphors there
and say light a fire under the dirty
diaper that wouldn't be good for anybody
you know what but people do that
do they huh who are these people they
make bad financial decisions oh yeah you
go i thought you were saying people
light fires under dirty diapers that's a
brand new sentence for me ken well
you've never had two wonderful metaphors
there that i felt the audience was going
there with me they were like oh what
would happen if you lit a fire under
see where we're going there listen it's
friday that's where you come from bad
decisions we're just warm bodies at this
point yeah don't here's the point of
that one don't compound bad financial
decisions you know you're gonna have to
be disciplined and sacrifice
and dig your way up i'm glad there was a
point thank you there he is he found one
there it is get out the wet wipes
all right good show good howard george
thanks to everybody in the booth thanks
to you america for listening this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show it's
where we talk about your life your money
your work and your relationships
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the phone number if you wanna
jump in triple eight eight two five five
two two five
i'm ken coleman george campbell joins me
this hour and we are here for you we're
having a good time uh but we're gonna
give you some practical advice so that
you can get where you want to be to
cover that gap from where you are to
where you want to be whether that be in
your money your professional life
uh or in your personal life so we're so
excited that you've joined us let's get
to it uh we go north of the border
border winnipeg canada uh george can you
name the uh name of the nhl franchise in
winnipeg boy i'm guessing it has
something to do with maple leafs no good
call that would be toronto winnipeg jets
there we go jay is there jay how can we
help
hi guys thanks for taking my call you
bet jay what's up
um
so i declared bankruptcy about uh three
years ago after a combination of a bunch
of stupid decisions my late teens and
early 20s um my question is
now that i'm
a couple years back from discharge and
i've been focusing on saving and
you know doing all the right things and
not taking on any any debt after that
i'm curious as to the best way to
improve my credit rating with transunion
and equifax given the bankruptcy
without taking on a bunch of dumb debt
products i know the conventional wisdom
is go get a crappy 20 loan and just make
sure you make all your payments but that
doesn't feel like something that you
guys would suggest me do so i was
curious about your opinions on that
well you know we don't get too worried
about the credit score and i understand
with bankruptcy it's a different
situation when that thing's dangling on
your credit report for what six seven
years
in canada uh
yeah about seven my i'm not concerned
about financing or anything like that uh
my fiance and i are in the process now
of looking for a new apartment okay um
and i know that we want to be looking at
purchasing a house in say two to three
years time now i know with our savings
rate we'll have about a hundred thousand
dollars in cash savings in about that
time so we'll be able to comfortably
afford a 20 maybe 30 percent down but
real estate is expensive here so there
will be an element to the mortgage if we
purchase a home at that time so
i want to make sure that
you know i'm prepared to be able to
enter into those things when the time
comes um and likely that you know could
be before seven years from discharge
yeah well i mean the only thing that you
would need or be worried about the
credit report and score is when you're
getting a mortgage because the rest you
said you're paying cash for right we
don't really need it to rent an
apartment you can do that without a
score you may need to talk through if
it's if it's a low score and the
apartment does a check on you and they
go hey what's going on here but you can
find a place that will rent you uh
regardless of your bankruptcy
okay and now on the mortgage side i
would proactively reach out to a lender
in your area and say hey listen i'm
about three years out i want to do a
15-year fixed uh it's going to be less
than a quarter of my take-home pay we're
going to have a nice down payment 20 or
more what does that look like for me
knowing that i have this bankruptcy
still on my file for another year so
okay and we'll walk you through what
that looks like
yeah jay thank you uh for the uh
question i you know george when you get
in a situation like that what's the
what's the mindset someone needs to
start with because there's always you
know a lot of fear you know there's a
lot of shame and baggage when it comes
to bankruptcy which is understandable he
said man i made some terrible financial
decisions and so i don't want that to
hold you back i mean the man himself
dave ramsey right filed many many years
ago for bankruptcy he's doing okay today
and so i don't want this to be kind of a
scarlet letter you walk around with
let's just look to the future and go all
right we made some mistakes we learn
from it we're going to pay cash for
things we're going to do things the
right way going forward and i think any
any lender especially when you're you
know seven years out if they say hey
sorry man you can't do this until it
falls off your report then we wait one
more year we have some patience we save
up more money have an even bigger down
payment and you just bought yourself and
pay some patience there so i don't think
it's the end of the world you're already
three years into this thing you're
living your life you're paying cash but
i would not worry about the score but i
would do my due diligence do some
research call lenders and say what does
this look like for me so that you're not
blindsided when the time comes good
stuff all right let's go to robert who
is in indianapolis indiana robert how
can we help
yeah hi how are you guys doing today oh
we're having a blast what's going on
it sounds like it hey what i've got
going on i'm uh i'm retired uh um also
on social security disability i i was a
police officer got injured at work i had
to medically retire through work and
then also
you know so i get both those pensions
my wife's getting ready to turn 62 here
pretty soon i'm 62.
i've been retired for eight years nine
years somewhere in there
and uh you know she won't get much uh
we're looking at about 900 from social
security she's a homemade homemaker for
most of her life
and i was wondering do i grab that and
invest that we don't need her money
um and she will always get mine if i
pass away and you know and that's that's
my my main thing uh uh i can wait till
she said me and draw our money and but
you know i don't know i'm i'm playing
the percentages i don't live that long
just from being a police officer and uh
usually our life expectancy isn't that
long after work so that's kind of my
question if if i need more i can give
you more so how old are you two
62. uh well 62. okay
yeah i mean i think it's great to start
drawing it down now and invest that
money since you don't need it yeah you
guys are living comfortably on the rest
of your income
yes i i get about i get close to seven
thousand dollars a month with social
security and uh and my disability that's
great and uh yes and we're we're fine
do you have a financial advisor
no i don't i was gonna look into doing
that yeah i would jump on
ramseysolutions.com and click on trusted
pros reach out to a smart investor pro
in the indianapolis area because they
can walk you through even doing the math
on social security and what if we waited
and what if we invest it now and where
should we invest i've done a lot of that
study of myself and of course i'm not
that you know but i've done that and i'm
i'm leaning towards taking it and
investing it is what i'm doing the
beauty of investing it is that that then
gets passed down generationally and with
your family
yes versus it going with you guys yeah
absolutely that's a great opportunity
but do consider uh
meeting with a couple of our smart
investor pros ramseysolutions.com just
so they can help you uh devise a plan
show you how it all works and then you
get super confident pick somebody you
got the you know the best connection
with and you understand everything
they're telling you this is a wonderful
opportunity to invest and uh you never
know you know uh don't sell yourself
short my man all right don't try to
check out too early and we appreciate
your service absolutely very very much
all right um george we're close to a
break here and uh the thing i wanted to
ask you again we're talking about
mindset on that previous call you know
dealing with bankruptcy and all that and
then again here's i feel like that's
another mind a money mindset question
which says okay
do we take the money now the social
security money now and invest
i think a lot of this comes from
confidence and both of these callers
like when we are very clear on what our
opportunities are how we can reframe or
dig out of a situation in bankruptcy or
in this case
how that money could be invested it
feels like confidence is such a key play
i think that's a real a big reason
people call in they're at a crossroads
they're not sure what to do they need a
third party to go okay i heard
everything you said heard all the
details here's what you need to do and
you do that with confidence and it
empowers people yeah
you're not sitting on the sidelines
anymore you're in the game yeah so the
takeaway folks is get clear on these
money issues and when you're clear
then you can be confident and uh
confidence gives you the courage to make
the moves you need to do to stay with it
as long as it takes to have true
financial peace all right don't move
more of your calls coming right up
[Music]
[Music]
so
the ramsay show continues i'm ken
coleman joined by george campbell and we
are here answering your questions about
your money your work
your relationships triple eight eight
two five five two two five is the phone
number that's triple eight eight two
five
825-5225
daniel joins us in temecula california
daniel how can we help
oh hi uh thank you so much for taking a
call yeah you bet can you adjust your
phone a little bit feels like you got a
sock covering up or something
sure can you hear me better a little bit
better yeah
oh
okay um i have a question regarding my
uh
property so i have two properties one in
california and one in
the state of arizona
and um i have actually equity on both of
them and um my question is should i sell
the one in arizona to pay my main
property in california how much do you
owe on the property in arizona that's a
rental
uh that one i owe a hundred in five
thousand
what's it worth
uh it's worth the
288 thousand
okay and what do you owe on your primary
residence in california
on that one i owe 165k
and yeah okay 165k all right what's it
worth
it's worth uh 680 000. nice all right
what kind of what kind of income if any
are you making on the house in arizona
uh on that one i'm just making about uh
300
300 a month ah yeah not much margin
there no for 3 600 bucks a year i'm
selling that arizona property and with
the net proceeds you're going to be able
to pay off the california property right
yes that'll be correct i love that i
think it's a no-brainer daniel because
you're you're not making enough money
for the headaches
in fact many months with any kind of
expenses you're losing money
so this is a great way to get out of
this and being a long-distance landlord
that's not fun longest it's landlord and
you walk out of this thing with a paid
for primary residence in california
it's a no-brainer which way were you
leaning when you called us
okay well i was leaning to that my only
um
question was because the property the
taxes in california are so expensive
so
um i was other uh also thinking about
paying my uh
property in arizona sooner than uh you
know because we financed that for 15
years from a 32 or 15 years but what how
does it affect property taxes if you pay
off your house
well i still i'm still gonna have to pay
taxes right sure
but as long as you live in california
you're going to pay the taxes anyways
yes do you are you talking about moving
from california to arizona
yeah i was planning to do that on the
future well how soon i mean like what
were you thinking five years ten years
what are we talking about
uh
actually three years
why three years what's what's holding
you in california for three years
uh i a job a new job that i have in cali
okay
well if you want to live in that rental
and you want to hang on to it that's
fine but it's i would rather just pay it
off and then you're going to have all
this money in your california house and
when it comes time you're going to be
able to pay cash for a spot in arizona
yeah a spot you love
yeah because daniel think about this
three years from now what do you think
your house in california is going to be
worth
um i'm not sure but i think it's
probably going to be a little bit more
than worse so now
so now when it's time to move to arizona
you're flush with cash
more than enough to buy a really nice
house in arizona
okay well that was my question i was a
little bit confused about it thank you
so much yeah you bet you got it thanks
for the call it's a good problem to have
i like that very good let's go to josh
uh speaking of arizona josh is in
phoenix arizona josh how can we help
hi it's nice to meet you guys so
recently me and a partner opened up a
new company and the one thing we're
struggling with is driving sales and
marketing structure for the company to
bring more business to the company
what's the uh business
so we saw air purification units which
go in an hvac system they took over 19
and we have testing for them to prove it
so there's a lot of i guess there's a
lot of incentive to buy this unit
because a lot of people do have a fear
of getting sick we have all the
infrastructure built up however we're
struggling and having people come look
at the units or make a purchase
okay is this a uh showroom type
situation where they have to leave their
home and come see it
no not at all they
we you could everything could be right
in the email or checked out on the
website so there's no showroom like a
cabinetry or a granite company is there
uh
what about good old-fashioned
door-to-door
so i mean we were thinking of going
through a door salesman because that's a
lot of solo people drive their income
but there's a lot of people involved in
door to door you know you have to build
the whole team which will result in a
headache we tried doing something called
the eddm to send mailers out and that's
still yet to no avail it's been around
two weeks and we still got a single call
so how many of these units have you sold
so
we haven't sold a lot of them because
it's just a new company which we just
built up and now we're focusing on
where and why and how should we market
this device
well i if you haven't sold any it's hard
to know why people are even buying it
have you done research on competitors
and how they're doing and what their
messaging is
yes so our competitors mainly they they
go towards also door-to-door but their
units are more expensive than ours but
ours accomplished the same thing and has
a fda registration but it sounds like
door-to-door is the winning strategy for
them
yeah it does but there's also a lot of
headache involved in why don't you start
small
is it just you and another guy
yes you just mean another guy well who's
who's it's your headache it's not a
bunch of other people why aren't you
guys out you know knocking on doors hey
i'll take this street you take the next
street we'll meet in the middle
i mean you guys got to get this thing up
and going there is no marketing strategy
that is just going to make the phone
i'm all over the why did you start this
business
we started this business because you
know kobe was a big problem and our
company believes in trying to reduce
that and you know give people peace of
mind in their own homes
but as as kofit kind of goes away you we
need a better marketing strategy and
messaging than fear of covid right
yeah so a quick question where jordan
i'm going where george is going
phoenix is is it a high allergy place
because of the valley i'm wondering or
no
yes it is and our devices also do
allergy removal which is in the phoenix
area that's what i'm talking about so
i'm a dad all right i got three kids and
so i'm gonna be thinking okay look this
is this gives you multiple benefits so
this is going to reduce the allergens in
your home and it's going to and
allergens lead to x amount of percentage
of colds and sickness plus this is uh
this is going to help ward off
covid whatever whatever you guys got to
get a narrative but but i will tell you
this you guys need to sell it to one or
two people have you sold it to anybody
at all yet
yes we have all right and and have you
stayed in touch with those folks
yes we have are they excited or are they
just like
about the product now that they've got
it
well our clients are actually really
excited about having this in their home
because their air changes drastically a
lot of them have been inclined to do
their other condos or their other houses
across the u.s great so you have to tell
the story and you have to incentivize
them to tell the story so what's your
incentive program to those few clients
if they were to tell the story on
facebook or their instagram or whatever
they send it out to 15 friends and they
show you the receipt of it and somebody
buys what's the referral program like to
where they are incentivized to tell the
story for you your greatest marketing
is going to be the customers that you've
won over who say this is really
effective and that it's just like
building a real estate business this is
going to be uh you know door-to-door you
know a water cooler people talking about
it at work and that's the marketing that
i think will be the most effective for
you do you understand what i'm saying
yeah i do so i mean this is getting busy
but you saying well george or kid i
don't want to have to hire people to go
door-to-door nobody's telling you to
hire anybody it's you going door-to-door
and talking to people you know
um and you got to hit that pain point
for people and when you hit that pain
point
it's like a frenzy and you've got to
lead with that it reminds me what was
that hippopotamus game we played with
our kids harry potter no no
you put the little marbles in there and
you hit it you got to give people
something they want this they got to eat
value maybe give them a free a free air
check allergy yeah free air check give
them something they'll respond like
those hungry hippos that's what it was
not harry potter sorry ken
all right don't move more of your calls
coming up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman i'm joined by my colleague
george campbell we are thrilled that
you've joined us today we're here to
answer your questions about your money
your work your relationships all those
are intricately tied together and if
you're not winning in one it's going to
affect the others
and so hey a question for you uh we have
a lot of new people joining all the time
so we've been listening and watching
whatever platform you engage with the
show on uh we appreciate you so much and
you know i know it's true of me i know
it's true of you george because we
recommend a lot of things to each other
that's true and you know when something
you come across helps you in your life
or you enjoy you want to tell other
people about it and uh so if the ramsay
show uh has helped you or you enjoy in
any way um it's become one of the
biggest business and finance shows in
the world it's because millions of
people like you tune in and can't help
but share so um we want you to share
so whether that be on podcasts youtube
or your local radio station please share
about the show and how it has impacted
you what you've learned what you're
doing
those are the stories we want you to
share the most is what you're actually
doing because you are the hero you are
the entire subject of the show so if you
do that we would be grateful we want as
many people as possible to find
um this content so that they
uh can live their best life as well
sharing is caring ken thank you george
that's a summary do you have that bumper
sticker on your uh tesla don't do bumper
stickers yeah not on the tesla for sure
yeah triple eight eight two five five
two two five let's go to green bay
wisconsin joy is there joy how can we
help
hi thank you for taking my call my
situation is pretty simple um i'm really
divorced i'm 70.
um
i had 45 000 in savings last year but
now i have 35
i'm and
i
earn only 20 000 a year because i'm
working part-time and i have no debt so
my question is um how do i make sure
that that 35 doesn't disappear now i
know you know that i'm supposed to be a
good girl and
control my spending and all that so but
i just wanted to hear your your feedback
okay so you don't have a mortgage
payment you have the house paid for
i went
and um my expenses per month are right
around 900. okay great and is your rent
uh fixed
it's not going to go up
well no if anything that'll go down i'm
in uh housing government housing right
now and it's working out really nice
okay so
and does that include do you have any
social security is that all of your
income is 20 000 a year
that includes social security yes okay
and you said you're working part-time
how much longer do you think you could
work for or do you want to work for oh
i'm pretty healthy i could work for
another 10 15 years probably yeah i like
that answer joy that is awesome this 35
000 it sounds like a big part of it is
your emergency fund
well you could call it that i just i'm
just happy to have it and i i do think
of that you know i do have
emergency fund and that thousand dollars
that you say you should have
good well it doesn't sound like you have
a lot of expenses and because you're not
a homeowner you don't have to worry
about you know the hvac going out so
that's nice right but i would still set
aside 10 or 15 as your emergency fund
and the rest of that money i might look
into investing because that money
sitting in a mutual fund over the next
10 years that can grow
and so i would get in touch with a
financial advisor we've got smartvestor
pros in the wisconsin area that can help
you with this if you just go to
ramseysolutions.com
connect with uh with one of those
folks and they can help you decide what
the best thing to do with you know that
20 extra thousand dollars that you want
to invest over the next 10 years
so that it doesn't disappear
with inflation yeah
one thing i have not done is uh getting
a off a funeral arrangements ahead of
time that i probably should do that and
i will i gotta do that today
absolutely yeah get a will done today uh
we have that resource as well for you at
ramseysolutions.com through our friends
at mama bear legal forms and it's very
inexpensive to do well and in there you
can put your funeral arrangements and
what you what you would like done
and um that would help and having that
money set aside with no debt you're
really going to be able to leave a
legacy in that way because you're not
going to have debt tied to your estate
yeah thank you so much joy for the call
and could you just say something for a
second
70 years old
she's like oh yeah i
feel fantastic i'm going to work another
10 minutes we get calls from someone
who's 52 and they go well about it's
it's about over yeah
that's sure what do i do
way too late and joy's like oh yeah i'm
going to 85 baby i like she's still
working i think and you can prove me
wrong ken but i think working at an
older age has really great benefits
without question sitting around watching
old reruns of the price is right it's
not going to keep you going very well
yeah yeah you know you don't even know
what the price is right is but i love
the reference i know that drew carey is
not my favorite host of the price is
right oh i'm a bob barker guy okay
george with total credibility there
dropping the bob barker on everybody but
yeah there is something to this idea of
longevity being tied to a sense of
purpose and hey i'm getting up and i'm
doing this there's no question about it
data shows that as well so engage
your brain engage your body is the older
you get the more you can get out and do
something and and and something that
matters to you
absolutely does have a tremendous joy
was a joy to speak with there it is
there it is all right let's go to julie
in sacramento california julie how can
we help
hi um
so i
i just got a uh my divorce judgment and
settlement um forty five thousand
dollars
and i don't know what to do with the
forty five thousand dollars and just
i don't know what to do with it i have
an idea ideas oh i'm sorry
how long ago did this happen
uh just i got the judgment like couple
months ago
and
i also noticed this check that my
ex-husband wrote me was dated march 30th
but then he um
he mailed it to me and i just received
it like
two three days ago
what was that was he hanging on to it
why do you think there was a gap there
i have no idea he's he's been he's been
like that
is that in addition to the forty five
thousand
yeah
so how much is it supposed to be fifty
thousand dollars
the judgment says uh fifty thousand
dollars but
he decided to tell me
not the judge he told me that he's going
to deduct 5 000 for
various reasons
so i that's another thing that um he
doesn't get that call yeah so the judge
needs to be aware of his editing
i know i don't know what to do uh but i
i don't even know if this check is real
because i just remembered now that it's
been march 30
i don't know
i think there's an expiration right
well if the money is still on the
account it should be good yeah no not on
writing the check but uh so so
do you have any debt you called and said
okay what do i do with the settlement
have you received the 45 000
yeah he mailed it to me yeah i have it
so is it in your bank account or is it a
check
it's not in my bank account i don't know
what to do with the check i don't know
i've just cut a frame okay
first things first i would deposit it
into your bank account park it in a
savings account for now
and we got to figure out what's next for
you financially are you having to move
what's your life look like now
uh i got my first apartment with my own
name on it
only because of the um
the child support money was coming in
consistently and it allowed me
to rent with my own name it was it was
my number was high enough that i can
rent it under my own name are you
working
i i'm not working right now i've got
like
three little kids um
i don't even know how
okay i'll tell you what to do
like most of the time
yeah so julie here's what we're gonna do
um
we're gonna we're gonna hold you over
because we we want to spend a little
more time with you you're in this uh
kind of this intimidating overwhelming
scenario of your life with three little
ones uh when we come back uh george is
gonna walk you through what you're going
to need to do financially
but i want you to hold on but i want you
to be prepared to answer questions like
can you work
think of any child care costs that are
associated are you there with them all
the time so you don't need it any debts
that you have if you can have that
information ready to go george is going
to walk you through this but here's the
deal hang on because julie you can do
this and we're going to help you this is
so important we just run out of time in
this segment so hold on and when we come
back julie we will give you a clear path
forward thank you so much george it
breaks my heart yeah it's time single
mom
starting over a lot of unknowns so
you're going to help her get clear this
can help a lot of people we're going to
give her some hope don't go anywhere
more with julie coming up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so welcome back america you're joining
the conversation here on
the ramsey show
our scripture today is proverbs 22 4.
humility is the fear of the lord its
wages are riches and honor and life our
quote of the day mark twain
do the right thing it will gratify some
people and astonish the rest i'm ken
coleman he is george campbell and uh we
held julie over uh from our last segment
for those of you that are joining us
right now and
julie is in a tough situation
now a single mom recently divorced
little ones
um not currently employed
got a divorce settlement of about 45 to
50 000 what do i do with it so she's
overwhelmed uh is now renting
uh but with the kids all the time so
there's a lot going on she's
she's uh obviously and understandably
feeling overwhelmed george and uh so we
we ran out of time and so we bring her
back all right julie you're back you
ready to roll
yes all right awesome all right george
cool so julie you said you had child
support how much are you making a month
in income and is it all child support
yes okay is there any alimony as well or
is the settlement take care of that
uh there was alimony
more
okay not anymore so what is your monthly
check and child support what is that
about 2 000
all right
and do you know your current expenses
for the month
oh my
uh
yeah i use a credit card
and then i use my
uh to help my point my credit score goal
up and then i use my the child support
money to pay the credit card
but i'm not even sure what the point of
me doing that anymore is because i i
mean i'm not like i'm getting a house or
anything i don't even know
why i'm paying my bills to keep my do
you have a balance on any of the cards
i always try to keep it zero okay so the
current balance is zero on all cards
it was 665 yesterday but i paid it last
month okay
well go ahead and cut up the cards
because this is not going to be a good
crutch for you as you as you climb out
of this and find a new normal i want you
to use the money you have on hand so
that we don't hurt this uh your
financial situation any further and we
do need to it sounds like we need to get
some income in the door
sooner rather than later
but it sounds like child care wise
you're going to be at home with the kids
right now is there an option for you to
go to work and have child care provided
for them
child care is very expensive it's worth
a thousand
or more per child how old are you
uh they're two
four and
seven the sevens in school but
um do you have any family support around
you
i wish
no family living locally
uh unless i unless i wanna take their
abusive comments i i've done that in the
past i'm considering doing that going
back to them
uh and just tolerating the
you know negative comments but we're
looking for support here if they can't
provide that we need to look elsewhere
yeah i i only even ask them i don't have
much often okay and the only reason i
ask that julie is i'm trying to figure
out you know child care options that
doesn't cost you a thousand bucks a kid
you know what i mean and so because you
you've got to bring in some income
at some point
um you don't want to hold yourself
hostage to his
uh ability to pay the child support you
don't want that
so do you have any other debt
at all besides the small credit cards
that you've got and we want you to cut
those up and not using those anymore do
you have any debt that you inherited
from the marriage or that you walked
away with
uh the my student loan debt uh
i had like
18 000
when i got married my husband and i paid
it off
and uh dave
the courts made me pay half of it back
so
uh to him so i i haven't paid him
anything
that's got to come out of the 45 because
i want george to walk you through what
you're going to do with the 45 000. so
if we cut him a check for what is it 9
000 that you owe to him what's the exact
number
i think so something like that 9 000. so
if we pay him the 9 000 and we don't
have any credit card debt we have no
other payments other than rent right and
just covering our basic
bills
correct
yeah
yeah okay the rest of that money is
probably going to be your emergency fund
right now because we there's a lot of
unknowns happening
so we recommend you have three to six
months of expenses tucked away in an
emergency in a savings account for
emergencies once you're debt free and so
that's where you are right now uh it
doesn't sound like you're going to be
able to invest or you know do any more
savings on top of that right now we need
some stability and that to me is going
to look like you uh finding a job that
can pay enough to then maybe cover the
daycare for the two for the two kids
yeah
that's correct because even if it's 1500
a month if you're making 2 500 a month
it's still a better option
than you're not working
so are you open to finding work
uh
i have to do the math because i if i
don't see the math in front of me uh
after my rent and utilities and
groceries and
you know i don't know
i would feel very uneasy
yes yes if if i can if i can see a
possibility it's like i have to see the
numbers instead of me i just haven't
done it have you done work in the past
what kind of uh work have you done
like do you know what you were doing for
such a long time
until my my divorce that i did old
instacart uh because
you know it was a court order
uh so i did instacart and then i noticed
significant curation of my wheels my
tires
in like two months wow uh hey
uh the gas prices up going on and then
i take my kids on instacart uh
but uh regardless of the dirty looks i
don't care yeah julie hey julie let me
let me encourage you with something you
know we live in a world today where
remote work is more prevalent than it
ever has been before
and you're talking about working from
home
and you know i know you got three little
ones
but i'm telling you to keep yourself in
a position where you are relying on the
ability to live and function on his
paying you child support is a
very precarious situation
and right now it feels safer to you by
the way you're talking
then actually going out and finding your
own employment
and taking care of the babies on your
own and then whatever he gives
is gravy
i'm telling you that you can work from
home you can find remote working jobs
where you don't have to put the kids in
daycare and you can start there
to where you ease into this because
here's the deal this was a traumatic
situation
this is a like a reset of your life but
the fact of the matter is
julie you are more than capable of
taking care of those three little ones
you know it and i know it
and you will do whatever it takes to win
and i'm telling you yes you're
overwhelmed and i know it's shocking i
know you don't have a lot of support but
one of the best things you can do right
now
is to provide for you and those kiddos
you still got to heal
and and you may need to go to some
therapy and
and and i probably recommend that
but but one of the best things you can
do for you and those kiddos right now is
go get a job whether it's remote working
in the home so they're there with you
the whole time
you're not driving around in the car all
the time that's a better situation and
that is extremely doable for you and i
would be looking for all those
opportunities and then the fallback
position would be where you you know you
get a good job because this idea that
you've been a stay-at-home mom
and you have nothing to offer
the workplace is crazy job numbers came
out today george
still 3.6 unemployment the economy added
350 plus thousand jobs
in the last quarter
the julies of the world can get hired
absolutely and julie we're gonna send
you a few resources number one we're
gonna put you through financial peace
university you can do that from home
watch all nine video lessons and with
that is gonna come every dollar premium
so that you can start doing a budget and
lay out all of your expenses lay out all
of the income and make sure that you've
got a plan for every dollar and also i'm
going to cook you up with a financial
coach in your area so hang on the line
austin will hook you up with a financial
coach where that session is going to be
on us as well as ramsay plus so thank
you so much for the call wishing the
best for you julie you got this
you got this hey george good show thank
you thanks for hanging out to james our
lovely producer puts up with us thank
you sir it's like the backstreet boys
it is like the backstreet boys yeah they
want it that way this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsay network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
you